T had been confirmed at Hope de Mont
site on Peer Road
my thoughts continue to be with the
victims and families affected
by that tragic incident
and indeed both tragic incidents that
have affected families and Islanders
over the last week or so
the founders of course have been made
aware
of the ninth fatality
and of before of course we have told the
public and the media and they continue
to be supported by our specially trained
family liaison officers
we believe there are no more residents
that remain unaccounted for
the search for the operation will
continue until the site has been
carefully and sensitively
cleared
fatalities that have been located and
recovered from the site
will now be formally identified
through our DVI a disaster victim
identification process
this may take some time
we have nearly reached the end of the
recovery phase of our response to this
major incident
and we've progressed much further than
we could have even expected just a few
days ago
over the last five days and it's
remarkable to think it is just five days
my colleagues across the three services
have worked tirelessly
expending remarkable effort in what has
been very very cold temperatures
wind cold even snow
to find the nine members
of our community
it is a testament I have to say to the
determination and the professionalism of
Jersey Emergency Services
as well as the incredible support that
we have received from the UK
particularly from our usar and heart
teams
who have been fundamental to this
operation
just from a policing perspective
we now have 26 officers on what we call
Mutual Aid
experts in dealing with the
investigation of major incidents
our home system which is that our I.T
system that helps us investigate these
sorts of things has been activated with
help and support from other forces
we have additional resources for
disaster victim identification and crime
scene investigation
we also today welcome three experts from
the National Crime Agency on fire a fire
and explosive expert gas and structural
expert and indeed an archaeologist we
have 15 more people coming to the island
on the 18th to help us again with DVI
and CSI crime investigation
advisors from the National Crime agency
in total 48 Specialists are supporting
what is an enormous operation and
investigation
forces from gloucestershire even in
Somerset Devon and Cornwall Dorset
Wiltshire and of course our close
friends in Guernsey and I've already
mentioned the National Crime agency as
well as help from specialist commercial
companies here in Jersey and the
National Police coordination Center for
which I am
enormously grateful
from an investigative point of view as I
announced earlier this week detective
superintendent Alan Fosse who is the
head of crime for states of Jersey
police will lead the investigation
currently with 20 full-time
investigators and an array of support
which I have just alluded to and listed
to support her with support from the UK
the investigation will be long
and it is complex
it will take weeks indeed it it will
take months
I fully appreciate
that families and friends of the victims
and our wider Community as a whole will
want to know and understand
how this tragic event occurred
we will get to that stage I promise
but it will take time
so I'm now asking for a degree of
patience as we begin to undertake a
detailed and meticulous professional
investigation
which will include the identification
and of course the inquests that the
families effective affected truly
deserve
thank you ladies and gentlemen I'll now
hand over to Paul Brown
thank you Robin
I too would like to Echo the comments of
the chief officer of the state of Jersey
police and and send our thoughts to the
families and friends of those who have
lost loved ones
I'd also like to thank Islanders for
their enduring strength and cooperation
over the last week
I visited the scene
every day and night since Saturday
I have seen firsthand
firefighters from the states of Jersey
Fire and Rescue service and our UK
colleagues operating with Relentless
drive and exemplary compassion to search
for locate and bring into our care the
members of our community we have so
tragically lost
to want to take such a task within this
time as a testament to the Joint working
between local and National Emergency
Services and the determination of our
professional Rescuers
our shared priority remains and has
always been those who have been lost
and the people they have left behind
we remain at the scene now as we have
throughout with between 11 and 16
firefighters 24 hours a day
I am and always will be grateful for the
support provided by Hampshire and the
Isle of Wight fire and rescue service
and even foreign rescue service
Essex foreign rescue service
buckinghamshire Farm Rescue service Kent
foreign rescue service Tyne and Weir
fire and rescue service and the Scottish
fire and rescue service
I'm also grateful for the ongoing
support from my colleagues in the
National Fire cheese Council
the nfcc's national resilience team
the maritime Coast Guard agency and the
ministry of Defense
now the direct role of the states of
Jersey Fire and Rescue service in this
incident will begin to wind down as they
move into the investigatory phase
gathers pace
we will support in any way we can the
investigation led by the states of
Jersey police with openness and
transparency and the Relentless drive
for the truth through facts
that is what the families of those we
have lost deserve that is what they will
receive
thank you
I would like to add as my colleagues
have that our thoughts remain with those
involved and their families
as we approach the end of the recovery
phase of our response to this major
incident
the involvement of the states of Jersey
ambulance service is gradually being
scaled back
however we will continue to provide
command support and medical support for
those working on scene
in the days following the incident the
hospital received three people
one person from the scene remains in
their care
a special thanks needs to go to our
colleagues in health and Community
Services who have responded to the
incident at the weekend and who continue
to support
and offer support throughout
I would also like to take this
opportunity to explicitly thank the
agencies that have offered and provided
tremendous support to us throughout the
last five days
those include my own team within the
states of Jersey Ambulance Service
ambulance services from Southwest West
Midlands
Guernsey London
and the support that we've received from
the Coast Guard
NHS England
the national ambulance coordination
Center
St John Ambulance
Normandy rescue
and the Jersey ambulance support unit
I would like to thank Islanders for the
ongoing Corporation throughout the last
five days we are returning to business
as usual and Islanders can contact us
through the usual lines
thank you
thank you Pete thank you Paul we're now
available for questions
foreign
from BBC Channel Islands news
um on Saturday uh the first press
conference you said up to a do you
expected that up to a dozen were missing
and part of the reason behind that was
you were unsure about whether people
were visiting the flats that evening
um you've now said you there's no one
left unaccounted for is there a chance
you could potentially find further
fatalities of you has any light been
shed on whether there were visitors to
the hodamore flats that evening thanks
Amaya it's a really good question you
you will understand of course back on
Saturday the importance of caution uh
numbers are very important and the
sensitivity is attached to that
uh shortly after that we were working on
on nine fatalities we do not believe
there is anyone else but we we have
certain other things that we need to do
but we think that we've found everyone
that's in that that wreckage
what would they say and other things be
other bits of rubble that we just need
to move on I don't want to go into too
much detail but we are confident that
we've found the nine uh as deeply sad as
that is
um we found the nine that we anticipated
we were fine
and um and he said that you know
investigations like this it will take
months but there are some big questions
that families of who've lost loved ones
would desperately want answering can we
expect more light to be shed on what
happened on Friday night when uh the gas
company and the fire Services were
called will there be any more details on
what conversations were had what action
was taken or will we have to wait months
for that as well
one thing you can be absolutely
confident of is is every fact resulting
in what happened on the night indeed
what happened sometime before that it
will start sometime before and will go
into the response as well I don't think
it's appropriate necessary to speculate
and indeed that's not what you are doing
um but uh I think it is now time to
allow the investigation to do what they
need to do
thank you
thank you Studio morale here from the
JPM baywick Express if I could ask a
question of the of the Chief Fire
officer um could you tell me a little
bit more about the independent
investigation that you've commissioned
into the cause of the explosion such as
how who or who will carry it out and how
many people are or will be involved and
just uh just how that will sit alongside
the police investigation led by
detective superintendent Fosse are they
for instance independent of each other
um I can't tell you a great deal at the
moment what I can tell you is we're
clear that the police have the primary
Duty and Primacy for the investigation
here in all in all aspects relating to
the Farm Rescue service it is the police
that will lead this investigation we are
clear about that any assistance we can
provide to the police we will do so
um but my commitment throughout has been
that it will not be states of Jersey
fire fighters who will do that so the
independence will be the fact it's led
by the police I don't know what shape or
form the assistance from the state of
Georgia police if any is required at the
moment there are there are experts
um you know that that are available to
the states of Jersey police says they
would be to us so I don't know what form
it will take at the moment thank you
thank you and and secondly um we all
fully appreciate that there will be a
detailed and thorough investigation into
the course of this tragedy
um we did receive um details this week
from andiam homes that Oakton Mall had
been connected to the gas network but it
removed um removed it from last year
sorry the last user
um who was not in the affected block was
removed in September and it then asked
Island energy to disconnect that
redundant Supply from their Mains
Network off-site can you tell me
anything more about that and is that
redundant gas supply to Hope DeMont and
the request to disconnect it part of the
investigation
um Julian you you will you will
appreciate that there is lots of
information available some of which is
in the public domain that's now part of
the investigation uh and I don't think
it's helpful necessary to speculate uh
what we will do as you've been given my
Assurance is we will better understand
all of those facts and that will be
presented in the in the future
Katia Fowler from ITV Channel
um just like Julian we were talking to
andiam homes yesterday
um and they were talking about the
cooperation over the last few days
obviously Island energy were on site
Friday night how has the conversation
been with Island energy yet have any of
those interviews begun and how
Cooperative are they currently being in
the investigation
um initially uh and until recently uh
uh the gas company were part of the
Strategic coordinating group to ensure
that we could keep Islanders safe and in
that particular area
part of that investigation has not
started yet that's not unusual but the
senior investigating officer has met
with people from the gas company as you
would expect so that investigation is
underway and how have the conversations
gone so far with the two of them as yet
uh clearly I would not go into the
detail about those and I don't think
necessarily that's what you're asking if
you're asking are we receiving the
corporation that we would expect the
answer to that question is yes
questions
any questions from Skye
thank you it was just really to find out
whether you envisioned that some of the
42 displaced families may be allowed
back to their homes for Christmas
yes we discussed this in the meeting
this morning that is an active part of
our agenda we would really like to get
those people back to their homes not
least of which we are just about to
start the festive period which is on our
minds uh every day really about how we
can do that
I can't give any guarantees about that
because there's a whole host of
different things including the safety of
the buildings that's an action that's
come out of a meeting today what we have
done is we've got some private effects
personal effects from those places on
behalf of the displaced people and we'll
do all that we can to get Islanders back
in their home but of course you'll
understand only when it's safe to do so
okay thank you very much can I just
finish by one thing and say my thanks
also to you the media uh in the
sensitive way that you've reported this
in what has been uh probably the most
challenging week in our most recent
history so I'm grateful for you too for
your your sensitivity and your
compassion thank you